because hello what's happening
so last night I watched autopsy of Jane
Doe brilliant fell and definitely you
should see it if he a new real horror I
know that's kind of like a [ __ ]
thing to say but a lot of movies these
days just rely on jump scares and this
doesn't really that much it's got a
really good feel attention throughout
the film and I really enjoyed it from
start to finish so that's my
recommendation of the film this is kind
of more dissing the scripted thing of my
thoughts on the movie so spoilers ahead
don't ruin it for yourself it's a good
film throughout the film as they're
doing the autopsy on Jane they see from
the outside that she's perfectly fine
it's only when they open her up that
they can see the scarring the damage yet
still on the inside and there's a lot of
[ __ ] up things that are wrong with
that this kind of works as a theme for
me and almost a metaphor for the entire
movie if you look at the start of the
film there's a house it looks fine on
the outside it's only when you get
inside that you realize oh [ __ ] this
place is completely messed up so make
fires went on in here and this theme
carries on throughout the film and it's
a big metaphor what the plots actually
about everything from the outside looks
fine it's only once you get inside that
it's all [ __ ] messed up a lot of
people have theorized that the Sun in
the film is actually just imagining the
entire thing and he's using this as an
excuse for wise murder people once that
kind of makes sense he seems fine from
the outside but inside he's messed up I
don't actually believe that's the proper
meaning of the film ever since I played
Silent Hill 2 whenever someone mentions
depression or stuff like that I kind of
get the metaphor in my head in the
conclusion of what that game was and
that sort of appeared in my head towards
the end of this so basically we find out
at one point that Brian
Cox's wife suffered from depression
couldn't tell from the outside but
inside she was really depressed to the
point that she killed itself again with
the hole appear and fine on the outside
messed up inside metaphor that the film
has actually believed that Jane Doe is a
physical manifestation of Brian Cox's
wife and all the suffering and
depression that she had and all the
guilt that he now has from not realizing
that and her taking her own life and
there's a couple of little hints
throughout the film point towards this
theory throughout the film whenever
something bad is gonna happen this song
let the Sun Shine in plays and we hear
Brian Cox say that his wife was
nicknamed ray by him because she was
like some some sunshine we also find out
that she killed herself and that she
seemed fine from the outside he couldn't
tell and it was only after she committed
suicide that you realized something was
wrong and throughout the film whatever
the deal with Jane Doe however messed up
inside she is she never once responds to
them or fights back or shows any real
sign of it in itself which is what Brian
Cox also describes his wife was like she
was fine on the outside and no one could
see that anything was wrong until she
committed suicide and they got closer
which kind of worked as a metaphor for
the film so it is this constant
repetition and I don't see why else they
would put this in if they didn't really
mean to kind of highlight yet there was
something wrong with his wife and this
is the guilt that's built up and then at
the end he kind of sacrifices himself
which is unwarranted because it doesn't
do anything to help his son and his son
still die which sort of works as the
guilt that he feels he blames himself
constantly and the blame led to
absolutely nothing the sacrifice is in
order to restore Jane Doe to what she
was intact and five she should have done
with his
it's kind of hard to explain exactly
what I mean
but I do feel that she is the physical
embodiment of something seeming fine
from that outside being messed up on the
inside like his wife they hear the song
sunshine throughout the film the wife
was a nickname right so I think she is
actually the physical manifestation of
his wife and the girl that he feels
anyway that's kind of my theory on it
it'd be great to hear what your theory
was on that maybe I'm completely wrong
maybe I blew your mind I doubt it
because I'm an idiot though comment
below if you've seen the movie if you
haven't make sure you do check out the
rest of my reviews at definition Cola UK
and I see you later Sun posts